c'est la première fois que je la proche
la jument de 11 ans de johanne blais
l'ena est venu au monde dans ses bras
leurs liens indéfectibles confinement
oblige elle a dû s'en séparer pendant un
mois jusqu'à ce jour
j'ai repensé aujourd'hui j'avais comme
une petite émotion le jeu même je me
retenais guylaine beaudoin retrouvait
elle aussi son compagnon
je m'en remets tout à l'heure je me dis
c'est comme aller retrouver un amoureux
c'est quand on a des papillons dans le
ventre le seul malheur on a moins de
surfer émotivement
c'est quelque chose parce qu'en plus
c'est il devient de notre équilibre
ça m'amène beaucoup puis bin dans une
période plus difficile j'aurais
peut-être eu besoin de sous d'abord un
certain contact mais je les poèmes et si
je comprenais très bien la décision
s'était justifiée au moment où ils ont
pris la décision maintenant je trouve
que c'est juste fille de rue auprès des
écuries
pendant cette période de séparation ce
sont les pension pour chevaux qui ont
fourni les soins parfois pour plusieurs
dizaines d'animaux et bergie qu on est
devenue maman de 41 chevaux d'un coup
même s'il était brossé et misait
l'exercice plusieurs auront un surplus
d'énergie à dépenser c'était quand même
une grande pression d'avoir la
responsabilité de la santé de tous ces
chevaux l'on a fait quand un
propriétaire son cheval voir à tous les
jours le connaît le sait c'est quelque
chose qui cloche le cette
responsabilité-là tomber dans notre cour
le vétérinaire est venue quelques fois
pour des coliques par exemple mais il y
à ces bobos que seul le propriétaire
peut soigner les chevaux c'est pas des
bibelots un don qui est des êtres
vivants ayant des émotions il ya un lien
qui se crée avec leurs propriétaires
donc on le sent tels que c'est se
déposent des comportements était pas
normal on avait des chevaux qui
s'ennuyait des chevaux qui étaient
anxieux
les activités reprendront graduellement
dans les écuries les propriétaires
pourront se rendre en alternance le
ministère indique travailler sur ces
nouvelles mesures
ici marièrent trudel radio canada
bécancour